wir haben bereits ein relikt einer
außerirdischen zivilisation entdeckt das
sagt immerhin der renommierte
astrophysiker und leiter der abteilung
astronomie an der harvard university
cambridge und er sagt jetzt nach solchen
relikten von außerirdischen sollten wir
suchen denn dann werden wir schneller
außerirdische finden klicks um science
im future gegen drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank für diesen
wirklich tollen themenvorschlag von
jakob der uns über unser klicks um
science and future telegate gruppe
erreicht hat der link ist und in der
video beschreibung klicks um hält sich
übrigens weiter in den top ten science
podcast bei apple
werde ich überhaupt nicht mitgerechnet
ich habe auch einiges dran geändert
inzwischen dort gibt es meistens noch
mehr infos und man kann ihn ganz
entspannt hören auch wenn man auf dem
sofa liegt und löcher in die luft schaut
beim einschlafen baden oder autofahren
schreib doch mal unten in die kommentare
welche gelegenheiten ihr noch so kennt
der originellste vorschlag gewinnt
achtung diesen supercoolen nano
experimentierkasten es lohnt sich es
entscheidet eine kompetente jury und die
gewinnspielbedingungen sind unten in der
video beschreibung verlinkt zum podcast
geht es ihr übrigens unter me oder mit
den links in der video beschreibung im
oktober 2017 war der interstellare
besucher um 9 uhr aufgetaucht ein
besucher also aus einem anderen
sternensystem entdeckt mit hilfe des
plans stars teleskops zuerst ordneten
die fachleute dieses objekt das sich
bereits wieder auf dem weg zurück in den
interstellaren raum befand als komet ein
später dann aber als assault getauft
wurde er dann ganz offiziell auf 1 2017
u1 humor und ist somit eine echte
premiere
das erste objekt das unter diese neue
terminologie für interstellare
asteroiden fällt für die mehrheit der
forscherinnen und forscher weltweit
steht mittlerweile fest dass das objekt
wohl während der planetenentstehung aus
seinem heimat system katapultiert wurde
seine form ist demnach zigarren förmig
dennoch sind noch viele fragen offen
ein us forschungsteam möchte mit hilfe
von computermodellen analysiert haben
dass es sich bei dem interstellaren
besucher um einen auseinandergerissenen
gesteinsbrocken handeln könnte die
gravitationskräfte der sonne könnten
demnach zu der besonderen form von oben
nur mehr geführt haben oder aber hat
sich dieses objekt aus staub und gestein
von kometen außerhalb unseres
sonnensystems gebildet und wurde dann
aufgrund von sternen strahlung durch den
weltraum geschoben so lautet jedenfalls
eine andere theorie für manche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ist aber der name des mysteriösen
objekts programm kurz zur erklärung die
bezeichnung um humor ist hawaiianisch
und meint eine art boten der aus der
fernen vergangenheit geschickt wurde um
kontakt mit uns aufzunehmen
dieser meinung ist auch der astronom
oder kurz a wie loeb und er ist nicht
einfach irgendeinen astronomen sondern
eben professor an der renommierten
harvard university und hat bereits mehr
als 700 wissenschaftliche
veröffentlichung verfasst zudem ist ja
auch teil des forschungsprojektes
breakthrough star schott bei dem
forschungssatelliten in das der sonne
nächstgelegene nachbar sternsystem alpha
centauri geschickt werden sollen man
kennt ihn also und dennoch zweifeln
manche seiner kolleginnen und kollegen
an seinem verstand denn awi löw geht
davon aus dass oben humor keineswegs
einen natürlichen ursprung hat in seinem
neuen buch außerirdische intelligentes
leben jenseits unseres planeten das
übrigens gerade in deutsch erschienen
der link ist hier unter mir schreibt er
dass es sich bei diesem objekt den
indizien zufolge um ein außerirdisches
raumschiff handelt das nach dem prinzip
eines sonnensegels durch den
interstellaren raum zu uns gereist kam
und das hat sich der harvard professor
wille nicht einfach so aus den fingern
gesogen er hat alle daten und fakten zur
hormon noch einmal genauer ins visier
genommen er stützt sich vor allem auf
die beschleunigung des objekts und die
ungewöhnliche form beides kann seiner
meinung nach nur damit erklärt werden
dass es sich bei ihm um ein
außerirdisches raumschiff oder eben ein
teil davon handelt dazu sagte in einem
interview mit dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland wenn die einzige möglichkeit
die fakten über humor zu erklären darin
besteht sich etwas vorzustellen dass wir
noch nie gesehen haben warum nicht über
einen künstlichen ursprung nachdenken
ich habe ein segel vorgeschlagen dass
nicht reflektiert genau wie ein segel
auf einem boot das durch die reflektion
von luftpartikel angeschoben wird
doch diese these dass es sich bei ihm um
ein relikt außerirdischer zivilisationen
handelt oder einer außerirdischen
zivilisation handelt war bereits von
anderen internationalen forschungen als
sehr unwahrscheinlich eingestuft worden
also wie kommt die luft jetzt zu seiner
einschätzung er bezieht sich zum einen
auf die äußere gestalt des objektes da
die auflösung der teleskop bilder sehr
gering ist gibt es kein foto von humor
nur doch die fachwelt hatte vor vier
jahren festgestellt dass die helligkeit
des objektes etwa in einem takt von acht
stunden schwankt daraus schließen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dass umarow rotiert die helligkeit kurve
lässt zudem auf die langgezogene form
schließen und diese ist anders als alles
andere was man bisher aus dem
sonnensystem kennt demnach muss das
interstellare objekt die form einer
zigarre oder aber einer scheibe haben
und zudem mindestens fünfmal so lang wie
breit sein und da sind wir auch gleich
beim großen problem der fachleute denn
wie soll solch eine spektakuläre form
auf natürliche art und weise entstanden
sein
mindestens ebenso spektakulär ist die
bahn des objekts denn bei dem vorbeiflug
an der sonne war also wohl nicht nur die
schwerkraft die aufruhr nur eingewirkt
hat nach ansicht der fachleute muss eine
weitere kraft am start gewesen sein
und da sind sich alle einig doch was für
eine
es gab die idee dass sich hinterm ohr
ein gigantischer eisberg aus wasserstoff
verbirgt den wasserstoff ist für
infrarot kameras nicht sichtbar
doch der wäre ja wohl bei einer reise
durch das all verdampft eine andere idee
um humor als eine art staubwolke mit
einer 100 mal geringeren dichte als luft
doch auch ein solches objekt wäre auf
seiner langen reise wohl schnell
zerstört worden viele fragen sind also
weiterhin offen
doch der großteil der forschenden ist
sich mittlerweile sicher dass es sich
trotz dieser ungelösten fragen um einen
kometen dann doch gehandelt haben muss
dazu aber in einem interview mit dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland das
problem ist dass humor keinen
kometenschweif hatte normalerweise wenn
sich kometen der sonne nähern verdampft
ihre eishöhle
und es bildet sich ein schweif im fall
von om uhr konnten teleskope allerdings
keinen entdecken dann hieß es na gut
vielleicht ist es ein stein ohne eis das
problem damit ist dass das objekt von
der sonne weg beschleunigte und mit
einer zusätzlichen kraft angetrieben
wurde die in etwa mit dem quadrat der
entfernung von der sonne ab nahm etwas
das normalerweise durch einen schweif
erzeugt werden kann aber den gab es ja
nicht außerdem war die geometrie des
objektes extrem und es gab weitere
anomalien alle sind allem war humor
etwas das wir noch nie zuvor gesehen
hatten wie lips meinung steht also fest
es muss sich um ein konstrukt von
außerirdischen gehandelt haben nur diese
theorie kann seiner meinung sowohl die
bahn als auch die form des objekts
erklären wie loeb stößt mit seiner these
allerdings auf unverständnis in der
fachwelt doch es gibt einige forschende
die genau wie der harvard forscher davon
ausgehen dass nur noch eine frage der
zeit ist bis wir endlich außerirdisches
leben aufspüren nach der ansicht von a
wie loeb ist es für unsere suche nach
zivilisationen jenseits der erde wichtig
dass sich nicht weiter auf die signale
ferner intelligenz konzentriert wird er
wirft die ideen im raum dass sich
zivilisationen auf dem weg zur
interstellaren kommunikation
unweigerlich selbst zerstören er
vermutet dahinter eine art naturgesetz
im klartext meinte also eine situation
so weit ist interstellare raumfahrt
industrie betreiben zu können muss eine
enorme technische entwicklung voran
gehen für diese dynamik möglicherweise
unweigerlich zur auslöschung dieser
zivilisation
wenn man davon ausgeht ist es glück
zufolge deutlich sinnvoller nach den
relikten ferner intelligenzen zu suchen
statt nach deren signalen
hinterlassenschaften wie raumschiffe und
sondern könnten demnach viel einfacher
dazu führen dass wir längst
untergegangene außerirdische kulturen
entdecken dazu sagt er
um ein radiosignal empfangen zu können
muss auf der anderen seite jemand am
leben sein der sendet das könnte eine
sehr limitierende anforderung sein
auf der erde zum beispiel gab es viele
verschiedene kulturen die in der
vergangenheit existierten auf ein
radiosignal der mayas warten sie jedoch
vergebens das gleiche ist im alter fall
die meisten technologischen zivilisation
könnten inzwischen tot seit vielleicht
weil sie das klima ihres planeten nicht
mehr fahren konnten
vielleicht weil sie von einer ihnen
getroffen wurden die chance ein
radiosignal von ihnen genau in dem
moment zu empfangen in dem wir danach im
all ausschau halten ist sehr gering aber
wir können nach ihren relikten ihrem
müll ausschau halten wie reporter die
die mülltonnen vom prominenten den
hollywood durchwühlen können wir anhand
ihres mülls etwas über ihr leben
herausfinden
wir bleiben natürlich dran am thema und
mehr dazu gibt es jetzt hier auf die
ohren im podcast also anklicken anhören
und abonnieren einen der zehn top
wissenschafts bottas klicks uns wahnsinn
future und vergesst nicht in die
kommentare zu schreiben wann ihr gerne
den podcast es wegen dieser kohle kohle
experimentierkasten ansonsten muss dann
bleibt dran